90 prozent aller waren werden per schiff
zwischen den kontinenten transportiert
viele schiffe auf den weltmeeren fahren
unter sogenannten billigflaggen für
viele sehleute bedeutet dass schlechte
bezahlung wenig sicherheit und so gut
wie keine rechte
das trinkwasser an bord war nicht
kostenlos man musste dafür bezahlen
der preis war davon abhängig wo wir
gerade waren sie mussten für trinkwasser
bezahlen ja manchmal war nicht einmal
genug davon da sie hatten nicht genügend
trinkwasser dabei da waren vielleicht
zehn crewmitglieder an bord
wir hatten aber nur 20 kisten wir
wollten bezahlen aber konnten nichts
kaufen weil kein wasser darum beim essen
war es das gleiche
das war das schlechteste essen das mir
jemals an bord eines schiffes angeboten
werden der seemann auf sri lanka zeigt
mir fotos von seiner zeit auf dem schiff
liter
das einer deutschen reederei gehört in
tollen hätten sie regenwasser gesammelt
das wasser sei aber ungeniessbar gewesen
der blick in ein glas mit trübe brühe
durchsetzt von schmutzpartikeln in
brasilien dieselbe situation da haben
sich dann einige crew-mitglieder
beschwert über die wassersituation an
bord der chef schlug uns vor sammelt
regenwasser in plastikplanen und füllt
es in regentonnen ab so dass es genug
wasser gibt bis nachschub kommt über
eine messenger dienst informieren die
seeleute fast einen monat lang
hilfsorganisationen über ihre
verzweifelte lage die letzte nachricht
kommt am 25 mai verfasst aus einem
brasilianischen hafen frühen morgen
haben wir dann endlich etwas zu trinken
und zu essen bekommen
das war das schlechteste schiff auf dem
ich jemals gearbeitet habe
in hamburg hat die liter festgemacht das
schiff auf dem der matrose über monate
arbeitete auf eine interviewanfrage
lässt die reederei blumenthal anwälte
antworten
es habe an bord immer proviant und
getränke in guter qualität und menge
gegeben
das hätten behörden kontrollen erwiesen
kein wunder
zwei tage zuvor am 25 mai hatte der
seemann geschrieben dass man wieder
trinkwasser habe das schiff fährt unter
der flagge von liberia
somit sind die behörden des
afrikanischen landes zuständig aus e
mails ergibt sich blumenthal wurde von
liberia über die bevorstehende kontrolle
informiert
die internationale
transportarbeitergewerkschaft hat ein
schiff unter litauischer flagge
inspiziert und es daran gehindert den
hafen zu verlassen
die hamburger reederei blumenthal ist
schon häufiger aufgefallen 2009/10
berichtete das australische fernsehen
über ein anderes schiff der reederei
ihr frachter anna elisabeth wird in
einem australischen hafen festgesetzt
die transportarbeitergewerkschaft kiew
wirft der deutschen reederei unter
anderem schlechte arbeitsbedingungen vor
geschafft hat sich ohne erlaubnis zugang
zu dem schiff verschafft man mache sich
sorgen um das wohlergehen der seeleute
jeder bekomme täglich nur eine geringe
verpflegung zudem habe der kapitän
wieder angaben zur qualifikation der
crew noch zur bezahlung machen wollen
von der reederei blumenthal wollen wir
wissen
stimmen die vorwürfe blumenthal verweist
auf ein gerichtsurteil wonach man nicht
behaupten dürfe dass es nicht genügend
oder schlechte lebensmittel gab
tatsächlich als das schiff von
australischen beamten kontrolliert wurde
war die verpflegung in ordnung dabei
will die gewerkschaft noch einen tag
zuvor verdorbene lebensmittel gefilmt
haben
in einer internen e mails äußern die
australischen bahn und eine vermutung
zwischen dem zeitpunkt der aufnahme des
fotos und unserer inspektion wurden
wahrscheinlich neue vorräte auf das
schiff geliefert
die reederei blumenthal hat ihren sitz
in hamburg vor dem unternehmen treffe
ich sven himmel
er ist inspektor bei der internationalen
transportarbeiter gewerkschaft
warum fällt in die reederei blumenthal
mal wieder so negativ auf weil wir immer
wieder wenn von seiten der besatzung
beschwerden gehört haben dass
lohnzahlung voll verzögert waren sei es
dass die versorgung mit proviant an bord
nicht ausreichend gewesen sein soll und
und/oder verweigerter landgang das ist
das sind so dinge dinge die gehen für
uns als gewerkschaft hatten natürlich
gar nicht wir reden darüber menschen die
sowieso schon einen harten job haben und
fernab der heimat fernab der familie
unterwegs sind die durch die natur der
schifffahrt an sich sowieso toller tag
für tag in einem gefährlichen umfeld
arbeiten wenn dann noch die die normalen
sicherheitsstandards sich gehalten
werden dann ist das unfassbar
keinem schiff der hamburger blumenthal
reederei hängt die deutsche flagge
das unternehmen hat seine flotte
ausgeflaggt
es gibt fragen die funktionieren besser
es gibt fragen
das funktioniert gar nichts ja aber
grundsätzlich ist das eines der probleme
die in die billig fragen für uns
darstellen
wie ist das da draußen auf so einem
schiff für ein paar tage habe ich eine
reise auf einem containerschiff gebucht
gelegenheit meine recherchen
aufzuarbeiten
zunächst aber muss ich zur sicherheit
zeitweise
[Musik]
was uns der seemann aus sri lanka
erzählte dass eine reederei nicht für
ausreichend trinkwasser und lebensmittel
an bord sorgt passiere immer wieder
sagen uns experten seeleute leben
gefährlich da ist die unberechenbarkeit
des meeres unfällen und bewaffnete
konflikte
wir sind mitten auf dem meer in
internationalen gewässern
welche regeln gelten hier normalerweise
fährt das schiff eines deutschen
eigentümers unter deutscher flagge für
seeleute gelten dann deutsche tariflöhne
und sozialstandards
doch viele reedereien umgehen dass das
schiff wird ausgeflaggt zum beispiel
nach liberia oder panama und das geht so
als erstes wird eine briefkastenfirma in
einem billigflaggen land gegründet sie
tritt als eigentümer auf das schiff
bekommt eine neue flagge an bord gelten
die regeln des flaggen start zumeist
schlechtere löhne und eine schlechtere
soziale absicherung
ich reise in die ukraine in die
hafenstadt odessa matrosen verbringen
monate an bord eines schiffes
medizinische hilfe ist meist weit weg
auch todesfälle gibt es auf einem
friedhof begegnung mit dem vater eines
seemanns sein sohn ist auf einem
blumenthal schiff gestorben natürlich
war es für uns unerwartet
wir haben nicht einmal geglaubt dass er
tot ist
für eltern ist das immer die größte
tragödie das eigene kind zu begraben
das ist die größte tragödie unabhängig
vom alter des kindes
die reederei blumenthaler praktisch
nicht geholfen
es war ganz am anfang da haben wir nur
diese information von der reederei
erhalten
der sohn ist tot und das war's wir
hatten so gut wie keinen kontakt zur
reederei die eltern des seemanns fühlen
sich allein gelassen
aber sie wollen klarheit ihr sohn starb
an bord des schiffes nahe der
algerischen küste in den akten finden
sie widersprüche
das ist das dokument in dem die
todesursache steht das haben wir zuerst
bekommen und dort wurde festgestellt
dass die todesursache unbekannt sei in
einem weiteren bericht wiederum steht
todesursache herzinfarkt bei der
identifizierung ihres sohnes entdeckten
die eltern verletzungen in seinem
gesicht
es gab zwei schwarze flecken rechts und
links an der schläfe und auf der wange
blutflecken sein gesicht war dunkelblau
und an diese zwei flecken
die eltern wollen wissen woran ihr sohn
wirklich gestorben ist
sie vermuten einen unfall
wir fragen bei der reederei blumenthal
nach was ist mit dem seemann passiert
schriftlich wird uns mitgeteilt
der seemann hat hepatitis medizin
genommen
das belegt dass er infolge der krankheit
einen herzinfarkt bekam die hepatitis
hat er bei der vertragsunterzeichnung
verschwiegen
eine auf seeleute spezialisierte
rechtsanwaltskanzlei in odessa kümmert
sich um angehörige verstorbener seeleute
die deutsche reederei blumenthal ist der
anwältin bekannt sie hatte schon
häufiger mit dieser reederei zu tun
blumenthal ist praktisch alle schiffe
ich meine die meisten schiffe unter
liberianischer flagge fahren
für jedes schiff wurde ein unternehmen
gegründet das als vertragspartner der
seeleute dient die meisten dieser
briefkasten firmen haben ihren sitz auch
in liberia auf diese weise konnte es
passieren dass die seeleute einen
vertrag mit einem unternehmen
unterzeichnet haben dem lediglich das
schiff gehörte blumenthal selbst trat
immer nur als betreiber des schiffs auf
allerdings wussten die angehörigen aus
gesprächen mit ihren verunglückten
seemännern das blumenthal vor dem
unglücksfall immer direkt mit den
seeleuten kommunizierte auch das gehalt
soll direkt von einem blumenthal konto
überwiesen worden sein
alle details und technischen fragen
wurden von blumenthal entschieden
die firma stand in direktem kontakt mit
den seeleuten in all diesen fragen
die rechtsanwältin versichert sie könne
alles belegen
zu dem vorwurf man beschäftige seeleute
über briefkastenfirmen erhalten wir von
der reederei blumenthal keine antwort
wer sich mit reedereien anlegt geht
risiken ein
schnell ist man seinen job los in prag
treffe ich einen tschechischen seemann
er hat ausgepackt 2016 war auf einem
frachter der bayerischen meint chip
reederei unterwegs
das schiff fuhr unter liberaler
billigflaggen jaroslaw muster an bord
des schiffes auch erleben dass die
arbeits und lebensbedingungen sehr
schlecht waren
darüber hinaus fiel ihm aber auch noch
etwas anderes auf ich bin in panama an
bord gegangen die fahrt sollte nach
vancouver gehen
die erste strecke war ziemlich kurz
gleich als ich angekommen bin habe ich
bemerkt dass dieser maschinenraum in
einem vernachlässigten und desolate
zustand war und dass dort irgendetwas
schlechtes passiert zehn tage darauf
habe ich die eigentliche situation
gesehen dass etwas mit den punkten nicht
stimmte auf seinem schiff wurde abwasser
mit ölrückständen vermischt und illegal
ins meer geleitet
jaroslaw sammelte beweise nahm alles mit
der handykamera auf wie soll ich das
beschreiben wie das aussieht
es ist wirklich so ein ölfleck auf dem
wasser so bräunlich mit farbigen flecken
und was ich gedacht habe als es
angefangen hat mit dem um punkten dann
habe ich meinen vorgesetzten
konfrontiert damit dass ich mich nicht
an so etwas beteiligen will dass ich das
nicht machen will
er antwortete er mache dass er 30 jahren
so und das sei seine angelegenheit und
dass das nicht herauskommt doch es kam
raus jaroslaw informierte seine reederei
die zuständigen stellen in liberia und
die us behörden
ein us-gericht verurteilte die
bayerische reederei zu einer
millionenstrafe
die richter stuften den seemann als
whistleblower ein und sprachen ihm eine
entschädigung von 190.000 dollar zu
seinen job als seefahrer musste er
aufgeben
heute arbeitet er als ingenieur der
kampf gegen die ausbeutung der seeleute
ist auch ein kampf gegen das ausflaggen
der deutschen reedereien
doch der scheint längst verloren im jahr
2000 von 1850 schiffe deutscher reeder
fuhren 717 unter deutscher flagge
das waren 38 prozent 2012 von insgesamt
drei 1784 schiffen sind 530 in
deutschland registriert das waren nur
noch 14 prozent 2015 gewährt der staat
den deutschen reedern massive
steuererleichterungen
das ziel die räder sollten ihre schiffe
wieder unter deutscher flagge fahren
lassen
der anteil deutscher schiffe stieg
daraufhin aber nur leicht auf 16 prozent
zählt man alle vergünstigungen zusammen
fördert der staat die deutschen
reedereien jährlich mit einem mittleren
dreistelligen millionenbetrag
denn noch einmal ausgeflaggt kommt kaum
ein schiff zurück was im schlimmsten
fall passieren kann wenn schiffe die
unter billigflaggen fahren die standards
setzen zeigen fälle von aufgegebenen
schiffen
laut den vereinten nationen traf es 2009
10 26 besatzungen geht eine reederei
pleite deren schiffe unter billigflaggen
fahren sind die seeleute quasi auf sich
gestellt
die seeleute bleiben meist auf den
schiffen zurück denn wer sein schiff
verlässt hat kaum noch eine chance
seinen ausstehenden lohn zu erhalten
die hafenstadt varna in bulgarien vor
anderthalb jahren legte hier die nica
von schülern
seitdem harren ein ukrainischer und ein
russischer seemann an bord aus können
sie mal ganz kurz erklären was das für
eine flagge da oben das ist die frage
die bedeutet dass wir hilfe brauchen
seit anderthalb jahren waren sie nicht
mehr zu hause
ihnen bleibt nur der telefonische
kontakt zu ihren familien als echter
lein
hier gibt es einen reporter bei mir ein
journalist er dreht ein video das ist
meine mutter das ist mein enkelkind das
ist meine ehefrau siehst du alle grüßen
dich wie geht es euch natürlich der
durchschnittslohn beträgt hier nur etwa
120 bis 130 dollar pro monat und die
nebenkosten sind total hoch und deshalb
sitze ich hier und warte auf mein geld
auf ihrer letzten fahrt 2018
transportierten sie glas über das
schwarze meer im hafen von warner war
plötzlich schluss
der eigentümer hatte angeblich kein geld
mehr während die übrige besatzung noch
ihre heuer erhielt gingen die beiden
leer aus jeweils 30.000 euro schuldet
ihnen der russische eigentümer ihr
frachter fuhr unter der billig flagge
von palau eigentlich müsste sich der
pazifik inselstaat für sie einsetzen
aber das sei leider nicht der fall
erzählen sie uns jetzt stehen sie
alleine da niemand kümmere sich um sie
wir verstehen das selber nicht als das
schiff festgesetzt wurde kam der
vertreter der flagge von panama an deck
und hat alle unterlagen abgeholt und
verkäufer er hat gesagt falls ihr
bezahlt werden und falls es keine
probleme mit dem schiff gibt dann bringe
ich alles wieder zurück die beiden
letzten seemänner wollen durchhalten
hoffen dass ihr schiff verkauft wird und
mit dem erlös auch ihre heuer gezahlt
wird
das würde seeleuten auf einem schiff
unter deutscher flagge niemals passieren
sagen uns experten seeleute unter
billigflaggen müssten hingegen immer mit
solchen situationen rechnen dass sich am
ende niemand mehr um sie kümmern
es scheint ohne kontrollen geht es auch
in der schifffahrt nicht so lange es
aber räder gibt die ihre schiffe in
ländern registrieren lassen
die nur wenig wert auf faire löhne und
ausreichende sicherheitsstandards legen
wird es vermutlich auch weiter
missstände geben wenn die
bundesregierung den rädern schon hohe
steuererleichterungen gewährt dann
sollten auch bedingungen daran geknüpft
sein
und zwar zum wohle der seeleute
[Musik]